from the gun so I think the ministers
explain the situation fully I regret
that the opposition of making political
points out of what was actually a great
success in getting our NHS staff
predicted does it does the minister
agree with me all that lot
my honorable my honorable friend is is
completely correct and some some have
short Memories We all stood up in this
house many of us to chipping ministers
to say why aren't you going faster why
don't you do more take the risk get the
stuff right we needed that was the
priority many people of course now want
to have it uh both ways they wanted to
criticize at the time for not going fast
enough not to take enough risk they
don't accept the fact that we are going
to be going through all the ones that
didn't perform and my honorable friend
is completely correct John Trick it
isn't it clear that slack Management in
the department led to get rich
elements of the British ruling
establishment
taking money from the NHS at a time of
national crisis their watchword was
greed rather than public service but my
question is this and I've notified the
rights I'll remember where is the
writable members in charge of the NHS
when all this was going on or is he
still in Australia get his 400 000
pounds for eating unspeakable parts of
the anatomy of various beasties
going on in the jungle uh but uh Mr
Speaker I think uh to The Honorable
gentleman's point it's the same answer
that I have given before there is a
clear process that every single um uh
bid to supply BP went through that
process uh regardless of where they came
from
James why thank you Mr Speaker during my
time as a member of the Public Accounts
committee we've looked closely at the
procurement of PPE and the National
Audit office found that ministers had
properly declared their interests and
that ministers were not involved in
procurement decisions so isn't the
reality that the civil servants who are
making these decisions were doing their
best to secure PP supplies for the NHS
and the front line in the face of a
global pandemic and while of course we
need to learn lessons from how this was
handled some of the people commenting
here seem to forget the intense pressure
we're under at that time
um my honorable friend is is completely
uh correct and when Mrs Justice
O'Farrell went through these cases uh
she noted in her something up that given
the time sensitive nature of the work it
was not irrational for the defense
department to decide that it was
prepared to take more risk than usually
would be acceptable because of that
extraordinary context that we are so
quick to forget in the questions that
we're hearing in the house today on her
birthday Christian Jordy thank you very
much Mr Speaker
um the minister has made much of the
context at the time of the speed and the
calls for PPE at the time but what my
constituents wanted and I'm sure
everybody else is was PPE quickly and
appropriately and earlier this year the
high courts ruled that the government's
VIP lanes were not only inappropriate
but unlawful and in breach of the
obligation of equal treatment so does
the minister appreciate that now
constituents across the country are
calling for an explanation and will he
back liberal Democrats amendment to ban
VIP lanes for all future government
contracts Minister Mr Speaker I've set
out the challenge we had a situation in
which uh MPS and ministers were all
being contracted by in many cases the
people constituents who were desperate
to help who had either contacts in
suppliers or where suppliers and sales
of BB they could see on the TV every
night the desperate need for PPE and
were Keen to helping that huge National
effort I've talked about the scale of
the operation to supply and source that
PP in the extraordinary circumstances
that we were in and away had to be found
to to manage all those contacts so we're
getting people all of us were getting in
touch to try and offer help and so
anyway had to be found to manage all
these things and that is uh what I've
described this morning and all of these
things just to reiterate went through
the same rigorous process as every other
contract Ruth Kevin thank you Mr Speaker
the uh the cabinet minister says that
lessons will be learned from the about
the about government procurement from
this PPE um Scandal so will he look at
the contracts that the home office has
on accommodating and feeding Asylum
Seekers which are ripping off the hotels
and the Food suppliers causing the
Asylum Seekers to live in on
malnutrition and squalor
these contracts have many of the same
characteristics vast profits and
executive salaries an opaic network of
subcontractors run by people who may not
pass fit and proper tests
I think it's stretching this a little
bit too far I know it's less has learned
but it's too clever and not clever
enough so we'll leave it at that
who should we go some Terry
oh sorry Steve Mr Speaker today's
Revelations show in my view further
evidence that the government's VIP Lane
was possibly criminal and exploited by
members of the party opposite so we'll
Minister today commit to publishing in
full the names of the Ministers of MPS
or officials who referred firms onto
that fast track Lane stop being evasive
we need to know what corruption happens
good news for The Honorable member as
far as we publish the information about
who referred in what contracts in
November 2021
Mr W speaker I hope what the minister
said Mr Speaker sorry not demoting you
Mr Speaker I hope what the minister said
earlier on about the process and how
meticulous meticulously it was followed
for every company that applied for
contracts during Kobe so what is it
about the the individuals or companies
that had associations with the
conservative party or ministers that
made them so Adept at getting through
the process
Mr Speaker as I said 90 of um uh them
did not get a contract so it wasn't that
they were being given some sort of
guarantee uh of a contract uh what I'd
say about that scheme is a way of
managing the contacts that were
happening uh with ministers so they're
being directly contacted they've been
contacted by MPS from across the house
on all sides of it and they had to be a
way of understanding what was happening
with each of those bids because
otherwise it would have been completely
overwhelmed but just to reiterate all of
them went through exactly the same
process not done by ministers but done
by civil servants of checking the
quality the price and whether they could
realistically uh deliver there was no
difference in the process that they went
through well then Toms
Mr Speaker these are issues that many in
the house on this side particularly
amazing for a long time now and my
ministerial interest public appointments
bill now in its third iteration has its
second reading next Friday so given us
current situation and giving it that
bill would help to address some of the
issues of transparency can the minister
assure me that the government will now
incorporate this into the program
Mr Speaker I will look at all the
suggestions that The Honorable member
makes
um uh very closely haven't had a chance
to actually look at the bill but I'm
sure that we are always in the market
for constructive ideas
being completely obstructive and
deliberately attempting to block down
the NHS trust in the Northeast
Northumberland NHS trust ROM uh
providing PPE from a factory of the room
at the same time people were closely
connected to the government were making
absolutely Millions from PPE ministers
is just a strange coincidence
yeah yeah
well Mr Mr Speaker the people who came
through the high protein were not all
politically connect people except in the
sense that they were being referred in
by uh MPS across this house
um uh I don't know the exact details of
the um the Northeast Supply that he uh
mentions if he um uh gets in touch I'm
happy to take that further them and to
provide him with a full explanation of
what the issue was with that bid for a
contract
yeah Mr Speaker can I thank the minister
for the answers that he's given but
there was a heavy use of the direct
award contracts to purchase PPE items
but as of April 2021 the Northern
Ireland 371 million primers paid for PPE
uh contacts and direct contacts does the
minister agree uh with hindsight that
there should have been a better insight
into the supply chains of where this PPE
came from who was making it after it
pushed the PPE contracts were given to
Chinese firms linking like the labor
schemes
um uh The Honorable gentleman's always
uh makes constructive suggestions in
this house and today is no exception
um he knows of course that we are both
uh that have an ongoing inquiry into the
lessons that can be learned and also
have a dialogue with the Health and
Social care uh Committee in this house
about many of these issues of course
Northern Ireland uh given its Heritage
was an important supplier of textiles
and um BP equipment inevitably given the
global balance of production uh a lot of
items did come from from China as he
says but I think in many questions that
we will be looking at as part of the
Lessons Learned we should be thinking of
course about domestic Supply
we've all seen the shameful Guardian
front page this morning but the front
page that sticks in my mind is the one
of nurses in Bim bags not PPE on the
front line but bin bags at a time when
everyone in constituencies like mine
when Luton Council was facing another
cut of a living million pounds people
are struggling so why isn't this
government
lifting every a finger lifting any
finger to get our money back and start
by releasing the records after the
mediation process
well vulnerable lady's question does
take us back to that extraordinary
moment where we did have a huge crisis
of PPE and we were desperate and uh
doing every conceivable thing we could
to get the PPE that those nurses need
and that is what I have been referring
to in my answers to questions this
morning but on the second part of the
honorable lady's question it is just not
true that the government is not lifting
a finger to get a bunny back we have a
process and we are going through all
this there's a substantial team in the
department working on it right now
many of us looking for the ability to
access contracts to Aid at that PPE
procurement and he answered the I told
you I remember for Alfred South the
information was published last year so
Patrick it can confirm for the house
this morning how many conservative MPS
were able to access or provide access to
this via VIP Fast Track line and how
many opposition MPS were able to access
this link fairly simple question yeah
yeah I don't I don't have that
information uh hand but I know for
example dive a seat on the edge of
Leicester an important textiles town I
had loads and loads of constitutions get
in touch with me and they wanted to say
where can I where can I go and what we
did is then send them onto a mailbox and
after they were in that office they then
went on through the usual process that
every single other supplier went through
another Chums of the conservative party
to be profiteering uh at the taxpayers
expense or shoddy unusable PPE
especially from their VIP procurement
Lanes at a time when people were locked
down into their homes and tens of
thousands of people including my loved
ones were dying is absolutely sickening
shameful and unforgivable so Minister
given that the British medical journal
estimates that the government has
written off approximately 10 billion
pounds for unusable uh undelivered or
shoddy PPE will he take this opportunity
to apologize to the bereaved families
for the amazing that absolutely the lack
of Integrity that at the heart of this
whole process
yeah it's because you're on what this
high priority route was and and was it
was not it was absolutely not the
guarantee of any kind of contract it was
a way of managing the huge number of
contacts uh that all of us uh were
receiving of help it did I think deliver
something like in the order of five
billion items of PPE all of which were
helping to save lives protect workers in
our NHS and in our social care settings
and of course we had to take up those
offers of help we had to respond to them
where people wanted to help in the
middle of a huge National and Global
crisis of course we had to to process
them but they were processed in exactly
the same way as every other bid for a
contract or something
Mr Speaker after he resigned Lord Agnew
wrote them in the financial times that
fraud and government is rampant public
estimates that are under 30 billion
pounds a year and there's a complete
lack of focus and the cost to society or
indeed the taxpayer the government's
economic crime bill that is currently
still in Bill committee is full of holes
and the government have refused uh
sensible requests by the opposition to
fill those holes in the bill will he
consider those government amendments
again in light of the rampant corruption
in government yeah sure yeah we keep all
these things under review because crime
bill is is part of um addressing some of
the issues that The Honorable lady is uh
concerned about
um I think we're blowing together two
different uh issues here slightly let me
finish the point uh in so far as he was
talking about the loan scheme but again
it relates back to the same issue about
the need for Pace that we were all
calling for in this house during the
time they need to get out loans to small
businesses which say tens of thousands
of jobs in my constituency and would
have sure have saved tens of thousands
of jobs at any other Ladies constituency
as well as part of that huge 400 billion
pound unprecedented uh spends to
preserve lives and livelihoods
Mr Speaker well BCB in my constituency
an accredited bonafida pre-pandemic
supplier to the mod adaptive production
lines to produce a range of PPE and
supplied Welsh government and other
public bodies like the police and yet in
spite of repeated attempts did not get a
look at not even a reply from the UK
Department of Health and today it seems
we might have heard why and yet in spite
of the shoddy way that he was treated
the MD Andrew Hull has offered to meet
the appropriate personnel and to discuss
any possible low-cost legal and easy
solutions to maintain British Supply
security of Central Equipment will the
minister now facilitate this meeting
yes Mr Speaker so I did mention that uh
due diligence was done on over 19 000
companies a huge number of companies a
huge number of people getting in touch
uh Dr Taylor absolutely uh let us um
continue that conversation I'm very
happy to talk about the particular issue
that she raised
yes the uh Mr Speaker the Welsh labor
government received 874 million pounds
for bpe as its population proportionate
share yet only spent 300 million about a
third of the money given and which it
suggests as Cardiff University the UK
government could have saved eight
billion pounds or 300 pounds per
household across the UK and it used
public authorities Health authorities in
Italy and councils instead of private
profiteering contractors known to
ministers will he look carefully at the
Welsh model and if you choose the public
sector are not private sector cronies
known to ministers like the former
Health secretaries I was out in the
jungle making more money for himself
I never inevitably speak a huge amount
of the PPE that is produced in the world
is produced by private companies there
is no world in which we could avoid the
use of private companies to to as
suppliers of this PPE PPE equipment
Peter Grant Mr Speaker my colleagues and
Public Accounts committee are an
important evidence session this morning
otherwise there's no doubt a lot more of
them would have been in here just now
the report that was unanimous agreed by
the committee earlier than the year on
PP contract stated at no pointless
consideration given to the extent of the
profit margin of potential suppliers
would be taking on payments for PPE
neither was consideration of any
potential conflicts between individuals
making referrals through the VIP Lane
and the companies they were repairing we
the public accountants committee another
mystery will therefore unsurprised to
see reports of excessive profits and
conflicts of interests and PPE contracts
and yet if today's Guardian reports are
correct the extent of lobbying of
cabinet ministers one of whom is back in
the cabinet by a senior conservative
politician went significantly further
than a public accountants committee with
a review of at the time can the minister
confirm that the reports of additional
lobbying in today's Guardian are
accurate and if they're not accurate can
you come back with a statement to
confirm that yeah yeah I read the same
uh school that's honorable a gentleman I
noticed that it didn't lead to a
contract in the case that was mentioned
in the guardian but more generally
absolutely there are many lessons to
learn about this process but we were
having to pay in some cases up front for
PP equipment because as part of that
Global Scramble for PPE that I've
described if you if you were not
prepared to go that extra mile you would
simply not find the PPE and we would
have had more nurses without that vital
equipment that we all needed
thank you master speaker I'm sure that
many MPS in this side of the house had
no idea a VIP Lane existed for PPA
contracts but even if I did know about a
VIP Lane for referring contracts if a
constituent came to me and said Alan I
have never
worked in the PPE environment I've never
ordered it before but I've got a great
plan I can order it from China just
referring with a minister I wouldn't do
that because it's impossible to do
proper due diligence so very believe
that this government accepted
recommendations from companies with no
involvement no expertise in PPE
contracts they still awarded these
bounds of pounds of contracts instead of
mediation with PPE Med Pro isn't a case
for the full investigations needed and
if the government's not going to do it
surely we need a public inquiry into PPE
procurement yeah yeah Mr Speaker we are
prepared to litigate whenever a company
didn't provide there is a process that I
set out earlier on in this process in
many cases there were people who did
have important contacts in China and in
other countries where PPE was being
produced it was important to pursue all
of those leads because we went we needed
to have a but to The Honorable
gentleman's point due diligence had to
be done and was done on all of those
cases in the same way I've talked about
the scale of the challenge in the 19 000
companies on which uh due diligence uh
was initially done and the huge drop-off
between uh that number and the 2648
company is that actually made it through
that filter so you can see in the
difference between 19 000 and 2648 that
there was a huge amount of filtering
done by that team by the 400 people who
were working so hard to try and get the
PPE that we needed to the nurses and
doctors in our NHS
that completes the Urgent question we
now come to business questions I call
the shutter leader of the House
thank you Mr Speaker to ask the leader
of the house that she will give us the
forthcoming business
thank you Mr Speaker
the business for the week commencing the
28th of November will include Monday the
28th of November second reading of the
finance bill Tuesday the 29th of
November consideration of an allocation
of time motion followed by all stages of
the Northern Ireland executive formation
Etc bill
Wednesday the 30th of November Committee
of the whole house and remaining stages
of the finance bill
Thursday the 1st of December
consideration of an allocation of time
motion followed by all stages of the
councilors of State Bill Lords followed
by a general debate on world AIDS day
the subject for this debate has been
determined by the backbench business
committee
Friday the 2nd of December private
members bills the provisional business
for the week commencing the 5th of
December includes Monday the 5th of
December remaining stages of the Online
safety Bill day two right honorable and
honorable members may also wish to know
that subject to Progressive business the
house will now rise for the Christmas
recess at the close of business on
Tuesday the 20th of December and return
on Monday the 9th of January the house
will rise for the February recess at the
close of business on Thursday the 9th of
February and return on Monday the 20th
of February the house will rise for the
Easter recess at the close of business
on Thursday the 30th of March and return
on Monday the 17th of April the house
will rise for the coronation recess at
the close of business on Wednesday the
3rd of May and return on Tuesday the 9th
of May the house will rise for the
Whitson research us at the close of
business on Thursday the 25th of May and
return on Monday the 5th of June and the
house will rise for the summer recess at
close of business on Thursday the 20th
of July and I will announce further
recess dates in the usual way I hope
that is welcome used by the house
thank you Mr Speaker I thank the leader
of the House for the business and the
recess dates
to Mr Speaker
tomorrow is the United Nations Day of
ending violence against women and girls
something I've been involved with for
decades so it is desperately sad that we
still have two women a week tragically
murdered by Partners or ex-partners the
same as in 1992 laws have changed but
sadly too many attitudes have not
and I also recognize islamophobia
awareness month and enjoy my honorable
friend the member for Manchester Gorton
in urging government to produce the
official definition of islamophobia
three years after they promised to
Mr Speaker I must admit it's a little
bit of infighting has hit the shadow
leader of the House team a little bit
more than the Bristol Channel divides us
this week with England taking on Wales
on Tuesday now I know the leaders party
will be far more prepared for division
amongst colleagues than we are because
they've had plenty of practice this year
but can I can I take this opportunity to
wish both home Nations well and who
knows maybe we'll be seeing each other
in the final
it Mr Speaker the leader's business
statement is Testament to her prime
minister's poor judgment and weak
leadership pulling Monday's roots on
their Flagship leveling up Bill Mark's
just the latest stage of the Tori's
long-running Psycho Drama in one corner
the Prime Minister desperately trying to
find at least some Manifesto commitments
he can still deliver on and in the other
Corner 50 of his own MPS threatening to
back an amendment against their
government's own bill complete shambles
government running from their own
backbenches leaving a leveling up agenda
in tatters and more importantly the
British people with a broken housing
market if he can't stand up to his own
party how on Earth is he going to stand
up against vestive interests does the
government even intend to continue with
the bill if so when are they bringing it
back
Mr Speaker since becoming Shadow leader
of the house I've had a ringside seat
for the chaotic way governments dragged
the Online safety Bill through
Parliament with the grace and decorum of
a reversing dump truck it was first
mooted a decade ago it's been four years
since they promised it in that time
online crime has exploded child sexual
abuse online has become Rife scams
proliferated and now I hear in a bizarre
move the government now wants to send it
back to Committee in order to try and
remove a crucial section that deals with
the legal but harmful content now the
bill was designed to deal with legal but
harmful conflict and self-harm and
suicide and racist content so why is the
government trying to take this out now
and if the bill doesn't come back soon
it risks falling entirely it will run
into the end of the session the leader
knows there's no option to carry over in
those circumstances so will we have
third reading on Monday the 5th will it
come back to the Commons in time to
finish remaining stages before the end
of parliament will she guarantee
there'll be enough time
but Mr Speaker it's not just the Tories
making poor use of parliamentary time
the SMP busy debating Independence and a
plan to turn the next general election
into a de facto referendum rather than
getting rid of Tories and delivering a
labor government the NHS
greatest achievement NHS bosses in
Scotland set out plans to privatize the
Health Service shouldn't they be working
out how they're going to sort out 15
years of SMP mismanagement and
underfunding instead
Mr Speaker another issue I've raised
before is government sending ministers
to answer questions who simply don't
have answers on Monday the latest
incident a minister dragged to the
chamber to answer an urgent question on
the cop to 27 climate conference who
said herself she's not the climate
Minister now members have important
questions to put to ministers on behalf
of our constituents can I ask the leader
and not for the first time to press
government on the importance of sending
ministers to the dispatch box who are
actually able to answer questions so
finally Mr Speaker if the parliament if
the party opposite can't fill the
legislative program effectively they
could make way for one who can does she
want to swap places as leader of the
house I'd be scheduling an employment
Bill within the first hundred days of
the next Labor government the
legislation for an economy built on Fair
pay job security dignity a race equality
law to tackle racial inequality and
legislation to kick-start a credible
strategy G for fairer Greener growth
that's what you get with the labor
government so she can swap anytime she
likes thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker well can I start by
joining with uh The Honorable ladies
good wishes to both England and Wales uh
for uh matches tomorrow
um and uh and wish them all the luck in
the world I mean it would be wonderful
uh to see them both in the final but uh
uh we may uh we may be faced with
difficulties if we if that comes to pass
um The Honorable lady mentions violence
against women and girls an incredibly
important issue and one I think that our
nation can take great pride in the work
that we have done globally on combating
this I particularly put on record
um my thanks to the FC Do's uh Envoy on
this I think there is a summit that is
taking place very shortly to help
consolidate a lot of the work on this
and of course the work
um uh that my neighbor Lord Hague has
done in the uh in The Other Place uh in
in putting the this firmly on the agenda
globally we have some great ngos in this
country who are also doing fantastic
work supported by the UK government
globally but we know there is still more
to do there are some nations in the
world where the vast majority of our
women and girls perhaps only one percent
of them will have not faced uh horrific
violence so we must continue to do what
we can to uh to ensure that every woman
and every girl across the world can grow
up in peace and security The Honorable
lady also mentions that this it is
islamophobia awareness month this
government is committed to end all
anti-muslim hatred uh our work ranges
from supporting tell Mama to places of
our places of worship and security Grant
which for this financial year is 24 0.5
million and of course we're bringing on
new measures as well to protect Faith
schools the work that dlac is doing
regarding the definition is progressing
my understanding uh from The Honorable
uh and I will correct this if this is
not the case but I understand there is a
difficulty with the apg's definition and
its compatibility with the equality act
but I know the department is is looking
at this and if that is not the case I
shall make sure the honorable lady knows
uh the the facts
um sorry that the honorable lady still
has not condemned the train strikes I
think even if they are in the run-up to
Christmas there will be many people who
will be working over Christmas who'll be
wanting to visit relatives around this
time and I think for those that
particularly are completely reliant on
train services this is very
disappointing indeed and still hope that
the opposition will support our
legislation to ensure that minimum
standards on these important services
are maintained with regard to other
legislation the leveling up Bill and the
Online safety bill I will be announcing
those in the usual that way they will
still be making progress to the house I
hope members opposite will support these
uh in important bills and The Honorable
lady mentions uh what what labor have to
offer in its legislative program in its
policies on this side of the house we're
tackling the serious challenges that our
country face in contrast Labor's
policies would make those things worse
115 billion of unfunded spending that's
Labor's policy which would fuel
inflation labor voted against the
effective uh one thousand pounds tax cut
for low-income families when it voted
against reducing the UC taper rate
they're not on the side of Working
Families they've no plan on illegal
migration they voted against the
nationalities and Border act and would
scrap the efforts we are making to deter
and frustrate illegal migration and I am
seriously doubt that a leader of the
opposition who voted to block us leaving
the EU 48 times really wants to deliver
on the brexit dividend I think the
public when they are asked will look at
Labor and see that they have no clue and
no plan and say no thanks
James Wilde
Mr Speaker on Saturday in the big
football match Kingsland town was
playing in the second round of the FA
Cup and the walks will be full of fans
backing the Linux as well as it being
live on BBC One for anyone else you
can't get there so in addition to
joining me I'm wishing the team the best
of luck for that match all my writable
friend find time for a debate on the
importance of football clubs to their
local communities
what a timely uh question from my
honorable friend I do join him in uh
sending his uh congratulations and of
course the the World Cup does present a
huge opportunity to get people
interested uh in the sport Grassroots
football is is absolutely fantastic in
uh in uh giving people that opportunity
uh encouraging talent and of course
contributing to health and well-being
Across the Nation so I thank my
honorable friend for for raising that
today smps person thank you Mr Speaker
and can I associate myself for the
comments made on violence against women
and girls and for islamophobia month
yesterday the Supreme Court Mr Speaker
ruled the Scottish Parliament can't
legislate for an independence referendum
without westminster's permission now I
should make it clear the s p fully
respects and accepts the Judgment of the
Court however it should be emphasized
the Supreme Court doesn't make the law
it interprets and applies it the court
was not asked to decide if there is a
democratic mandate for a referendum and
the court was not asked what democratic
means remain by which Scotland can
choose its own future this ruling proves
Beyond doubt that it is no longer if it
has ever been a voluntary or an equal
Union so the situation we're now in
transcends Arguments for and against
Independence this is fundamentally an
issue of democracy do the people of
Scotland have a right to
self-determination and if we do can the
leader of the House tell us how that
right can be exercised if the Scottish
Parliament doesn't have the power to do
so if the people of Scotland keep
electing a majority of pro-independence
msps and MPS then what is the Democratic
route to realizing that mandate will the
UK government recognize that Democratic
Injustice and amend the Scotland act so
that right to self-determination for the
people of Scotland is protected or will
it continue to deny democracy now later
this afternoon a Westminster Hall
debates taking place on the infected
blood inquiry and compensation framework
a terrible tragedy that continues to
devastate lives last month following
Decades of campaigning the government
paid interim compensation payments of a
hundred thousand pounds to those
infected and bereaved widows and
partners however the families Estates
and carers of deceased victims are being
excluded from any interim compensation
which is an enormous Injustice and the
UK governments that carrying that out in
plain sight my constituent Justine
Gordon Smith is the executive for her
late father Randolph's estate Justine
was her father's carer throughout his
painful struggle and ultimate passing
and she herself has suffered enormous
and Lasting personal trauma so can I ask
the leader when will people like Justine
receive Justice and will the government
make an urgent statement on the specific
issue of such excluded family members as
my constituent yeah
well I Thank The Honorable lady and I
have to say I hope she had a good
birthday yesterday I understand it's her
birthday yesterday no it's not oh no my
intelligence is wrong I I well I'm glad
to hear that because I thought it would
be very unfortunate if it fell on the
same day as the uh the Supreme Court
ruling
um
I uh just starting with the infected
blood inquiry and the the compact
interim compensation